[Music]
thank you so much peter
uh that was fantastic and i i
i'm really excited that you can join us
here live tonight from the interval
we're able to
have both of us here in the studio
although across the room um
and um so welcome thank you for joining
us
it's great to be here it's actually
interesting to watch yourself as opposed
to actually
forming it and coming off that talk so
it's interesting to watch
me uh talk to you nice
cool well i mean i think it's it's it's
especially interesting to
you know in the middle of a pandemic to
have a positive view of the future and i
think it's it's welcome and i think
you know as as you and i have both
discussed there were through the roaring
20s came out of the last pandemic
and um i think it's it's important to
know that at least there is a version of
the world that can be much more positive
than the one that we're currently living
in so
i want to especially thank you for that
because i think it's it's a difficult
project to do
now um and i think we need it
but i want to just talk a little bit
about that in that
you do mention this kind of storytelling
trap and
most of these things having positive out
outcomes
of course there's going to be some
things that have negative income
outcomes or a you know a weird thing
like a pandemic or a
comet strike or who knows what it's
going to be there'll be something that
happens in the next 30 years
that um that is negative and um
how do you want to address that in
context of this piece
well one of the ways i think about this
is the culture itself is just
filled with um
[Music]
all kinds of dystopian roles out in all
kinds of ways
all the disasters are going to happen i
mean any side five programs tv shows
magazine articles cover stories and man
all the things it is we've we're just
bombarded with this so one of the things
i'm trying to do is overcompensate and
and you know it's a conscious choice
of trying to stress that what is getting
lost
in this look ahead in the future is
essentially all these positive
developments that are inexorably kind of
going along they're kind of in the
backdrop
they don't get the same drama i mean you
know the rise of middle class globally
the rise of you know the kind of
urbanization that's
a positive thing i mean these things are
just backdrop statistics that
occasionally surface and people miss
and so in many respects in this story
i'm just trying to focus on that knowing
full well
that there's going to be a completely
crazy bunch of things that are going to
come up here
including wild cards that'll set us back
um for sure it's gonna happen and it
will happen
it's kind of i mean basically it's kind
of the one one step forward two steps
back two steps forward one step back i
mean is this that's just the way
progress happens that's the way
technology rolls out that's the way kind
of
economic booms happen we're going to go
into a crazy period of time here and
there is
absolutely going to be a lot of negative
stuff that's going to happen and there
are going to be times where we'll be
ringing our hands thinking oh my god
it's over
but i think what i'm just trying to lay
out there is what is missing
uh and largely missing certainly when i
started this project was like you
couldn't even find anybody kind of
trying to talk about the positives of
the next 10 20 30 years
i will say it's shifted differently
literally just in the last couple of
months you're starting to watch a kind
of a conventional
kind of a news way to frame that coming
off the pandemic with the pent-up
consumer demand and you're going to
watch with the
with the uh the vaccines coming together
and actually opening up
the economy again that you're going to
see some kind of a boom
i think of that as a relatively short
term consumer boom kind of the
beginnings of
like you say the post-pandemic kind of
roaring 20s that is a
for sure true thing it is happening and
it will happen but i think what i'm
trying to get at is these deeper things
that will keep playing off for 10 20
30 years and that we haven't really
thought through fully
what it all means i mean when if we are
going to shift
even the vast majority of our energy
system on the planet to clean energies
over the course of the next 30 years i
mean just think of the economic
opportunity
that and just think about the scale of
change that's going to be needed and
just think of all the businesses and
jobs and all this kind of stuff
i mean people kind of know it at some
level and they kind of think okay yeah
somehow we got to do this but they
haven't really
thought it through and i think when you
do think that through and you do think
that through all these other things
these
inextricables i was telling you and see
them in synergistic kind of alignment
it really makes you think oh my god
maybe we are heading back into something
uh that is going to be quite
extraordinary
indeed well i'm going to move over to
some questions from our feed
and then we also have one of the people
you mentioned one of our founders kevin
kelly who will be joining us
on the stream but we have one of our
other founders you mentioned stuart
brandt
watching on the feed and sending a
question by text he says pete why is it
easier for people to understand and
believe a negative scenario than a
positive one
you know stuart that is a great question
i've been thinking about it for the
longest time
my basic way of thinking about it is
again with the long lens of kind of long
now thinking um
is i just think humans have been wired
from the beginning
to actually be anxious and afraid the
russell in the bushes you know it was
it was those humans that heard the
russell in the bushes and freaked out
like it was the freaking lying
that actually survived in a way that the
person that just was a little more
laddied on not worried about it and kind
of blue sky thinking oh it's nothing and
then they got you know they didn't move
on
and so i think it's it's really just in
us
it's just baked into humans of just to
actually be constantly anxious
about everything and it's been a
survival thing it's been something
that's just right there
so i think it plays into um that's one
thing i think that happens is people
start think when they think about the
future they think it's they go into it
with fear that's one thing that's
interesting
the other thing i would say is just from
the point of view of someone who's been
doing this and
as uh through wired and global business
network where i actually work with
stuart
um it's just so much easier to do
negative scenarios i mean it's just easy
to unwind anything just
blow stuff up makes things bad people
turn out evil
you know it's like easy and that's why
every damn you know cheap movie b-movie
you know tv show that's barely you know
thought through it's all negative and
it's all just spins out disasters right
easy to do much harder to make a
compelling
positive scenario much harder to show
get make it exciting and engaging that
people can actually
see positive things coming together now
i think
i've been always waiting i've been kind
of proselytizing but she'd have a thing
called a
genre of movie called blue sky sci-fi i
think honestly we could actually have a
whole category of
these things where people spin out
actually positive features that
ways things work and i don't i actually
it's just
it hasn't happened maybe there's some
just formula that just never works but
my gut feeling is particularly these
younger generations they want a can do
forward thinking this
could work frame as much as oh my god
we're doomed it's all going to go to
hell you know and i think
i think it might have been we might have
been that was more of a boomer thing you
know maybe maybe we're going to kind of
go into a kind of more uplifting period
here where you know people just
soon kind of see the positive stories tv
shows
books conversations whatever that's a
little more speculative for me but i
would say
easier to do and also people just are
wired to freak out and they're not wired
to actually think confidently and
thoroughly and consistently
uh about the future that's what we need
to do that's part of the long-range
thinking and i think one of the things
that
long now has been doing and i think one
of the things this community's been
doing is trying to
structure structurally and rigorously
think forward and also often with a
positive and more optimistic frame i
think it's an instant
indispensable thing that right this
community but i mean i think also one of
the
things the ways that we create a
positive future is by envisioning
negative ones and creating the
antibodies as a way and creating the
kind of
the story that we don't want to have
come true and so that's
in some way that's that's that's one of
the ways we create this negative future
so we tell that story enough that we we
invent the things that stop it i think
that's
entirely about i think that's true but i
think there's just enough of that going
on that boy we need a few more of those
positive ones in there i think i think
he's gotten po
the zeitgeist of despair in this country
and in the world in the last five
three to five years it's just been just
debilitating i mean i think it's just
gone on too much
and we need to kind of counter and i
think we're actually starting to see the
counter forces starting to pop up here i
think people are ready for
for a positive reframe well
i'm gonna ask uh one more kind of
question on urbanization before we jump
over to kevin kelly we have several
people asking questions about
urbanization
and i wanted to ask about it too i mean
obviously one of the biggest um
reasons we could have a reversal trend
against urbanization was something like
a pandemic and we're seeing that to some
extent
at least getting people further out to
the suburbs you know san francisco and
new york and
la are kind of we're seeing now a
decrease in population which uh
you know christie from our feed points
out um
and then that and on top of that we have
these uh connectivity trends which are
allowing people to
knowledge workers at least uh work from
more
remotely um and so i just wanted to ask
you know what is what is your take on
that
on that trend both of de-urbanization
um and are there limits to the
urbanization that we currently have that
that we're going to see
uh interesting questions one that
everyone's hanging out here
my quick hit on both the two kind of
points i'd really
like to make is cities have always
emptied out in pandemics
and they've always recovered and always
come back and they've come back stronger
and bigger and
whatever for always there is something
just like i said there's something wired
in humans to kind of freak out about the
rust in the bushes there's also a
fundamental piece about social animals
particularly
ones who like uh physical intimacy it's
frankly sex and connection with people
in in a way that goes beyond the virtual
that i think is just
this inexorable pull that the cities are
going to have now that said
uh uh so i'm not counting out the the
cities on the coast and all you know san
francisco
it's been told it's been dead for how
many times and it just keeps coming back
but i do think what is interesting about
this next phase is because of the
high bandwidth connectivity and because
of the virtualization so much which by
the way is going to get even more with
virtual reality and all the stuff that's
going to go even deeper emission
of virtualizing things uh i do think
we're going to see a
uh a revitalization of cities in the
heartland smaller cities all through the
place i mean you're watching right now a
lot of people
frankly the superstar cities were just
getting unlivable for
for everybody i mean no one can buy
houses you couldn't move in in
you know traffic around here and stuff i
mean in some ways people are just
in the bay area here where i'm in and
where you are is like finally we can
just drive around and finally we can
actually
do some things that have just been so
hard to do right yeah
talking to kids who are starting college
this year
uh they are pretty ready to get out of
their homes and dorm rooms and get back
to a party for sure
um all right so we're going to invite uh
one of our founders and one of the
people you referenced in the talk kevin
kelly
um who worked with you a little bit on
this piece as you were going
i will say kevin kevin i've had many
conversations with kevin and he has been
very instrumental in helping in this
project and helping
influence my thinking over the last 25
years absolutely thank you kevin so glad
to be here
you did a great talk pete i was inspired
i want to be part of that future
please let's make it happen i'm down for
i'm down with it
let's do it so um
one of the questions i would have is um
what kind of reaction do you get when
you tell this
very positive story to people maybe
people who have heard only the
pessimistic
view do they find it persuasive
can are they able to believe in it
in general are you able to convert
people
um that's an interesting question i i
would say
people are are what's wrong the wrong
word wired people's their knee-jerk
reaction to it is oh that's
too positive you can't be too positive
it's
that's just not how the world works it's
not workable
uh it's it's dead end it's not a
non-starter i mean that's honestly and
there's a lot of
super smart people um who when you talk
about this it's just oh no no
no no and i think there's something
weird about that i think i think what it
is
is i think educated people intellectuals
particularly are kind of
um raised and are just surrounded by
news magazine analysis books i mean all
the kind of intellectual thing is
almost i would just put a number on it
you know 80 percent of it is somehow
negative you know
and there's a lot of people kind of
ringing their hands about the negativity
of news and stuff but when you're kind
of in
environment like that constantly and
just it's just seeped into your pores
it's just the way you think about
everything
when someone comes around with a totally
different way that's positive and
reframed
and kind of has it's thought of as naive
or it's thought of as like uh
you know oh that can't be right or
anyhow there's just some weird
things so yeah it's a frustrating thing
i will say this it's not just this
project i've been doing this i've been
doing this
for the last 25 years i've done a lot of
public speaking and i'm always
positively saying it i will say this
people love at least to go for the ride
for the hour-long talk or something they
actually like to do it because it's so
rare to do it and they're kind of like
wow
wouldn't that be cool there's a lot of
them that actually do that and so
um i don't think it's a lost cause to
push that
rock up the hill but i do think because
i think people are
open to it and when they see it they
have a thrill for it but then they
pretty much settle back into their
negative space so i think it's more like
maybe building a movement or building a
body a consistent media landscape that
has more of this i don't know it needs
it needs more
voices it needs more energy it means
more ideas that
this and i know you've been thinking
about this too um with your protopia
thing i mean i think people
need to things to hang on to they need
to grab it they need stuff and that's
really what this project was was just
let's get something in writing which is
where
in medium by the way anyone can watch
this uh the transformation it's a series
of six stories
in there um this talk will be one and
other venues and i'm going to kind of
keep pushing this because we just need
to keep
banging the drum that uh you got to stay
open to this and
really not only open to it but really
engage it seriously and think
why not i mean why isn't why isn't this
why is the narrative right now that
we're on the cusp of an amazing
era of reinvention of america amazing of
era of scaling up
to solve global problems to kind of
harness ai
and take advantage of biological
engineering and why isn't there this
kind of totally you could amaze
you can imagine a narrative of that it's
based on the tools the reality you can
there's people doing it in million
different directions but that's not the
narrative the narrative is this
everything's screwed up everything's
gonna go wrong everything's gonna
you know ai is gonna overrule us biotech
is gonna you know we're all gonna be you
know mutants and anyhow
you know the whole story it's it's it's
a
it worries me but it's something i'm
doing my best to counter it's best i can
so so um your your vision your story has
a little bit of a very global
kind of tech view the politics are very
us
focused i increasingly have come to
believe
that more and more the future is going
to be
decided by non-americans
the young non-americans of the world
that you kind of hint at
and um do you have a sense
of of their politics and
wouldn't that be a better audience for
this
talk is the young of china and india
because in a certain sense those are the
people who are going to be making our
future
good point i know that's something that
you've always championed in and one of
the exciting
things about the connectivity that's to
come and this again
kind of uh interconnection through
language and
and uh understanding is going to come
with the
potential to do that i mean you know
right now it's hard to figure out a way
to actually communicate and
really get your eyes out your ideas out
that way so anyhow it is something that
i
um i know that's maybe not the best way
to answer your question but
i do think uh to the extent we're going
to be able to kind of
proselytize and spread the word i think
i think what it is is for those of us in
the west here is to actually uh
help energize and help empower
essentially the folks i do think will
build the future
i'm a little worried about the china the
chinese
way i do think there's still two systems
existing right now
and although the liberal democracy
world is kind of decadent and not
working very well i'm a little
concerned about a kind of more
authoritarian kind of
chinese version and to what extent
that's
uh i i think of it they're comparable
they're straight off with both
and i think that's why i see them as
allies in the solving climate change
thing but i don't know
if um i don't know which is
better in the long run and i'm so i'm
still not kind of going that
as far as that so so uh maybe my last
question is um
uh i i'm with you that we don't really
need to to
drum up more dystopians and negative
scenarios because
there's machines that do that already
very well but i am interested
is is if you had a magic wand that could
remove
one hurdle the biggest hurdle you see
for this
vision coming true what would that
one hurdle that you would like to see be
removed
what is the sort of the biggest headwind
against this
half happening
wow that is an interesting one um
from the global point of view from the
americans from the global point of view
if it was a magic wand if i could
literally just do a magic wand
um
to me what's missing maybe this isn't as
big enough to swing with my magic wand
that i have
but i but i think if what i think is
missing right now
is people cannot comprehend they cannot
think they cannot envision they can't
see
how a better future works in a kind of
more comprehensive way they don't
understand
how could the economy work to be more
kind of equitable and kind of
rework wealth differently and deal with
mitigating inequality
they don't understand how would we
really uh
solve climate change in the you know
reasonable time here to kind of stay
under the
kind of global warming kind of levels
that we got to worry about they don't
see
how would you rethink a more global
world that is kind of working on a
planetary scale and you know beyond the
borders of a bunch of collection nation
states i mean there's a bunch of things
that people are just
they don't get it and so they say hang
back and they
hold in their their their their kind of
position and they even look backwards
and say well god wouldn't it be good if
we just did it what we did in the 20th
century or
you know some people are going back all
the way to the founding fathers and
saying you know originalists you know do
what they did you know
in the 1780s like anyhow it's a backward
looking thing
so i but i think what's happening is
it's hard to envision that future it's
hard to see it and if there's some
way maybe it's different kind of media
different kind of thinking
different kind of mental tools or
something that would just
help people see more clearly rigorously
thoroughly
comprehensively what could lie ahead
i think it would energize uh people to
do
to start doing it in a way i think it's
it's right now it's it's it's
missing the missing piece is the
envisioning piece
and not into a kind of trite way of just
you know build a better
life and we're all going to be better
it's like how do
do these future systems work how could
they work can i
mortgage my future on it can i mortgage
my kids future on it can i
you know move in that direction can i
let go of my own
career and move into that career i mean
it's hard for people to see that and
that's why i think the whole field of
futurism and i think the whole field of
of kind of thinking uh systematically
about the future is so valuable and it's
so
still crude and still kind of unformed
and i think boy if i had a white magic
wand some way we could just do that with
more
kind of uh christmas and and clarity
and uh to make it things more convincing
i think it would be awesome and it would
mobilize political will
and energy in new ways uh that i think
we're lost right now because we
can't make people see it and this is my
little vague way of
in this you know talk or this series
showing one way
that if you just suspend this belief a
little bit and think about it it's just
helping people
see that through life see what's out
there
uh it's a pale attempt it's one attempt
but uh boy we need more of us doing it
that's what i would say
where's my wand well your magic worked
on me this evening so thank you
thank you well it's always good to hear
that from you kevin i appreciate that
thank you kevin really appreciate you
joining us tonight um we're
wrapping up the q a right now we're past
the top of the hour um i will say
this this talk generated more online
questions than i think any one of our
online talks
so far so you've definitely got people's
attention
um and but we have we have several
questions one from nick
uh one from michael hertz on this kind
of where does decentralization and
centralization
play out i think you know we see forces
of centralization right now
you know obviously in the big huge tech
companies like facebook
um and apple and these kind of silos of
technology that are owning google that
are owning so much of our
online world we see versions of
decentralization
with uh forces like um you know more
open web type sources like wikipedia
winning out over
britannica or um you know these you know
craigslist largely winning out over
you know online classifieds of other
types um
and i think now we have other forces
that are kind of coming in sideways to
that like cryptocurrency
um obviously being another
decentralizing force that are
potentially an economic decentralizing
force and so i just wanted you to
if you have a chance to talk a bit about
where centralization and
decentralization both either technology
and econo
economics um work out in this
yeah great good question um and uh
for those who asked it and yourself too
here's the way i'm thinking about it
is um in the relative short term
i think the force of decentralization
are actually going to
[Music]
be where the energy's going to go um and
i think
you know the era of you know the nation
state we all look to you know
biden in his cabinet to solve everything
that that's that area is less and less a
thing that was kind of a thing and it
was a 20th century thing more it could
be less less it's more like oh what's
california doing or what's the crypto
crew you know
energizing you know some outfit and you
know whatever another country anyhow
there's
i think there is a decentralized thing i
think this also includes tech
uh i think um but here's
but here's the here's the difference so
there's a decentralizing thing that i
think is
still the predominant thing energy of
where the where the air is going to go
but here's the problem and it's an
interesting switch and i spent a lot of
time thinking about this as i talked
more civilizationally we didn't really
get into that and that's part of the
talk just you can only do so much in 35
minutes
but um the ultimate challenge that's
going to happen to the planet
particularly if we try to solve climate
change in a way that's going to
work is we have to operate on a
planetary scale and it seems to me that
there's going to have to be some kind of
global
governance at some level or global
coordination
that i don't necessarily think it would
be centralized like it's going to be
some little cabal of people that runs
the global planet but there is some kind
of
another level of world historical
not centralization but coordination at a
global level that we've never seen
before that we're going to need
that's going to happen i would say
increasingly in the next 30 years but
across the century that is going to be a
thing um
but uh but anyhow and so it's this
global
reconnection at a global level beyond
the boundaries of states and
and nations and stuff that is is is an
energy that's going to take the whole
century to figure out but basically
that thing is what's also screwing up
and countering this uh decentralization
thing so for example the reason these
tech companies
are all so huge right now there's just
one simple reason the digital
environment is totally global there's no
boundaries on
on that and so when facebook can have a
two and a half billion people
on their platform and that was only
because
there's a global economy they're
seamlessly tied into right
so but that's not because oh that's the
best way to organize social media
is you know centralized it's just like
hey 15 years ago they started this thing
the borders were open globally they
scaled
they just kept scaling and in fact
frankly they didn't even know what hit
them they
moose grew so fast now they're like holy
what are we now one of the most
powerful companies in the world i mean i
think this is the thing people
overestimate they think that all these
tech titans you know where these
wanted to take over the world no they
didn't even know what to hit them
there's just
there's like this is wild ride for them
as it is for anybody to watch this
happen
so i think it's not like that's the most
successful way to go it's that that's
the scale we're starting to work at it's
globally and so i think
it still is nimble decentralized
uh innovative um i mean all that thing
is still
better and ultimately we're gonna see
facebook and all these are going to go
the way of you know ibm and you know the
whole thing i mean it's like it's just
going to we're going to watch the cycle
again who's going to be the next
updraft is it zoom or whatever anyhow
there'll be something but it's not
because the superior thing
is oh the big centralized thing this is
it's it's essentially this scaling thing
that we haven't
really thought through fully and we
haven't really understood
and that is going to be one of the
biggest challenges in the next 30 years
is going to be
figuring out how do we do that because
it's inevitable
that one i'll say is inevitable it's
inexorable too but it's like
uh by the end of the century we're going
to organize the planet on a
you know it's going to be one system it
is already one system at some level
we just haven't figured out how to do it
very well right yet uh but it's it's
gonna happen
again i'm an optimist so i'll say we'll
see
well and that leads perfectly into our
last question
uh we have several questions really on
you know on growth economics growth
of everything you know we know one of
the other things the inexorables and
demographics that's going to happen in
the next
um 30 to 50 years is peak population and
we already see it as i said in the in
the developing
or developed world and we're going to
see it in the developing world
where populations are starting to go
down and so economics are
likely going to be have to start
shifting in the way that they um
that they work so i'm just wondering um
you know
do we think that there's going to need
to be different economic models i think
when you publish this story and for
instance there was a
book came out called dow 30 000 which
everyone totally ridiculed
and strangely we actually hit it in the
middle of a pandemic
you know certainly maybe a little bit
later than that person expected but if
we did hit it and
went blue right past it in the middle of
what should have been the you know most
global economic downturn
that we've ever ever had so clearly
these things are starting to decouple
already from normal human trends and
demographics
to other things so i i just wanted to
get your thoughts on where growth leads
in the next 30 years
and how that plays out in this in this
world well okay i thought you're going
to go in a different direction that but
i'll just say two things about this but
i think it's interesting so what you
mentioned is
in the 90s when we kind of projected out
to 2020 um
it was true uh on top of a tech boom and
an economic boom
the stock market was going to go we
didn't push it but it was clearly the
thing and in fact it happened
but here's the thing is it was again
that was a thing of again
the scaling thing it's just like people
people don't understand exponential
that's one of those actually if you
really want to get down to it is
most people don't understand what
exponential growth is and i was trying
to show in those charts about how it's
happening now and energy is happening
in in biotech and it's we we've been
happening in infotech
and so these things go from manageable
and understandable to like holy how
did that happen
and so i think that's kind of if you
just heard my talk here
i'm not going to be telling you oh the
stock market should collapse tomorrow
and it's all a bubble i'm actually i'm
not saying you know the current stock
market in the choices are you know
necessarily
the future but i would say there is
going to be an insane amount of wealth
to be made
in the future here and i think we're
going to watch that happen now the
critical piece of this which i thought
was what you're going to go to is
it cannot happen on the old technologies
in the old carbon energies if that
happens we're screwed i mean we're
totally doomed honestly
but i think this is the beauty of what
the moment we're in here
is we can actually grow the entire
global economy on
clean energy sustainable everything the
way i say this is like you know
synthetic biology
packaging will be you know grown rather
than kind of plastic and petrochemicals
and anyhow all that kind of stuff there
is we know how to do this now and now
we don't know how to do everything about
it but we're past the tipping point of
understanding that
one last little thing i'll say about
this which which i um
which is a good way to think about this
which is we are so
lucky that the pandemic hit in 2020
rather than just
20 years ago in 2000 if we would have
hit 20 years ago in 2000 the same
pandemic
there would have been about 25 million
50 million
americans online and nobody else you
wouldn't have these open channel video
things all over the world you wouldn't
have scientists coordinating all
over the planet you wouldn't have kids
being able to go to school and video
everybody work from home that gone 20
years ago that's all it takes second
thing is we wouldn't even have cracked
the first human genome we didn't even
know how to
do a genome and uh now we're following
the
you know the viruses mutating by the day
and it's like everybody can do it and
they share it instantaneously that
couldn't happen
uh and the same thing was uh we crashed
the global account we paused the global
economy and all the
oil industry crashed and you know
everything crashed if this had been 20
years ago there's no way we could have
scaled back up on clean energy
like solar or wind or any of that it was
so immature it wasn't there so anyhow
the point is
we're lucky it's today the triple whammy
happened today we're lucky
because we could actually do all that
amazing think what's gonna happen
another 10
20 30 years we're going to be
increasingly lucky
that oh we could solve the global
climate crisis of 2040 because holy
we've
everybody has ai enabled everything and
you know we got sensors all over the
planet blah blah blah anyhow there's a
bunch of ways that happens so i just
think it's a we we need to keep thinking
um
how this is possible uh and we're uh we
got to
keep our minds open our imaginations
over what could happen in the next 10 20
30 years has happened
and i think i think we're past the point
where we we now
can actually grow the global economy
robustly and still
not blow out the planet and do it on a
sustainable kind of everything plan
and uh you know it's not gonna be
perfect it's gonna be one step forward
two steps back kind of thing as we
mentioned but over time
if we have this conversation in 2050 uh
most of this will largely have played
out because this is what i'm trying to
say
nice well we want to extend the invite
for you to come back in february of
oh 2050 um to report back on the things
that
that came out as as planned and the big
surprises that uh that hit us over
though i won't do it
as long as the interval's open and you
can actually get a drink rather than
kind of
uh been sitting in a pandemic like this
but yes by that time we won't have to
worry about pandemics
yes i will do that looking forward to it
i'm also looking forward to being part
of this community in the next
25 years here 30 years to it and uh
thanks for having me here indeed well
we'll step outside and have a
have a rare interval drink uh outside uh
shortly after this talk so thank you so
much for joining us i really appreciate
it
appreciate it thank you and i want to
thank you our long now audience for
sticking with us during this pandemic
and during these pre-recorded talks
we'll have more coming up in the future
and thank you so much
you